Tim good to have you back how are you
well I'm doing great how are you doing
I'm doing okay it's been a while you
look like you're doing a whole lot now
now you've added baseball here so uh
when does baseball when did the love of
baseball the possibility of baseball
start for you well the possibility
actually started a couple years ago
something I started thinking about hand
it's honestly something that never
really left me you know if I would be
you know speaking at different
universities and they were hidden BP I
might go out there and just always loved
it and what something that was the
second hardest decision honestly to give
a baseball to go to Florida to play
football and so it was something that a
couple years ago I started thinking
about and so I brought it up to throw on
my agents at CAA and they kind of look
at me like well you know a lot of
athletes probably think they can do this
but you can't really start to fill the
baseball age and I said hey will you
just come take a look at me like
honestly like no bias just come take a
look at me if you think I can't do it
just tell me
and so we flew to a place in Florida
where they're having some competitive
games or whatnot and so when had a
little workout and he you know saw
something that he he liked and so we
started to pursue it well actually that
same day in the middle of probably my
fifth at-bat [ __ ] Kelly called and so my
brother it was like hey Chip Kelly's on
the phone hands me the phone and so and
then I had to make a tough choice
because I was really thinking about
going baseball bin but the Eagles that
offense everything look good so I was
like well alright I'll you know give
that a shot obviously that didn't work
out and I started you know putting in a
time and training and so kind of the
rest is history yeah when's the last
time you got a call from somebody with
the NFL I'm not sure I mean honestly
it's still my dear son cause about
other positions but I'm not even sure
have you did you think about playing
another position not really honestly it
was just I think for me it was
it's always about pursuing what's on
your heart what you love what you're
passionate about and I love the game of
football but what I really loved doing
was playing the quarterback position and
and so I had a lot of you know good
opportunities to play other positions
but that just wasn't on my heart it
wasn't something I wanted to do if I was
going to make a change I would rather
make a change to baseball to pursue it
because I love it and I'm just grateful
that that we're in a country where we
get to pursue what we love and I don't
have to do what maybe a lot of other
people want me to do I get to pursue
what I want to do and what I have a love
for in a passion for and the two
greatest things I loved in sports when I
was a little boy was hitting a baseball
and playing the quarterback positions
and and I liked both of them because
they're really hard you know you go
through out of 10 in baseball you're
really good and the quarterback position
everybody's counting on you it's your
job to get it done at the last in the
last couple of minutes of the game
and there's those are just two passions
that I had and so you know grateful that
I get to go pursue it have you reached
out to Michael Jordan I have not I did
because I don't know if he could help
you since you know he was transitioning
into baseball after leaving the NBA and
went down to the minor leagues to do it
I don't I don't know if I mean if he'd
be a sounding board he could give you
any advice or is it something you just
have to experience yourself I'm sure you
could probably give me words of wisdom
but I think it's also something that
you've probably learned a lot from
experience as well is Tim Tebow the SEC
Network analyst Mike's been Trophy
winner where is the Heisman Trophy it's
actually my parents house in
Jacksonville Florida like behind
my sister's wedding photos and like in
the back there you probably wouldn't
even be able to see it if you're in
there I asked Jameis Winston that
question this week he says he hasn't
seen it since he wanted that his dad has
it he doesn't even know where it is
so well I would prominently displayed
put it on the hood of my car tomb if I
could if I want a Heisman Trophy yeah
whatever it takes to show that sucker
off I'd be fine with that what what's
the what's the next part of the baseball
schedule so what what do you do now well
I'll be showing up in a couple of days -
uh yeah start practice and instructional
and then star games a little bit after
that and figure it out from there
can you be too muscular I'm sure you can
be too muscular if it if it hurts your
mobility and flexibility but I actually
feel like I have pretty good mobility
right now and you know I think yeah that
is something that in baseball you know
you need to have and but I also think
being strong helps me hit the ball far
so I'll try to have a good balance of
both who do you look at as that's that's
the kind of hitter I hope to be I don't
know I think you know I've been blessed
to work some with Gary Sheffield and he
was just an awesome hitter and so being
able to take certain things that he did
I'm more of a wider approach and less
bat movement than him but I think just
how smooth his swing was would be that
would be something awesome to try to you
know emulate one day every time that
your name comes up or you've been on the
program inevitably somebody will say why
is he not still playing in the NFL how
do you answer that when people say why
are you not playing in the NFL oh I
think you know how it answers that
everything happens for a reason
I'm grateful for that and so I just you
know I'm great
for what I'm doing right now and my
opportunity with the nests and I'm truly
excited about it and pursuing this
things and you know I had a lot of
awesome areas in the NFL and that was a
really fun time especially with the
Broncos but you know I think you know
that was for season and we'll see what's
gonna happen next I know you're joining
us on behalf of Allstate I'll let you
explain what you're doing with them well
I've been blessed to be part of the off
day AFV a good works team and what that
is is you know what's also so many of us
love college football and we love the
passion and the tradition and now the
playoffs is done and and you know how
cool it is but I think this is so cool
because we don't aren't just celebrating
these kids for what they do on the field
but we're celebrating these 24 kids of
one coach for what they do on the field
and not just what they do but who they
are
and you know it's amazing to hear the
stories and see the stories of the way
these kids are changing their
communities and to Derick McCartney at
Colorado this year you know donated his
bone marrow and saved somebody's life
deshaun Watson is helping Habitat for
Humanity build homes and he has his own
personal testimony of how it changed his
life but you know on and on of kids
making a difference in their communities
and people's lives and I just think it's
something that's really important to get
out there because we spend so much time
talking about wins and losses and
Championships and but what's really
important to have the right perspective
this who these kids are and in how
they're going to affect their
communities and these kids are really
changing lives and bringing faith hope
and love them that's something to be
talked about and it's something to be
it's something to be celebrated really
and so that's why I partnered with the
SBA hey I'll say good works team and
it's been pretty fun awesome I'll leave
you with this I want you to be honest
could you start for the Cleveland Browns
right now I'm not throwing fast balls to
you at the
Lane I gotta give you a change up here
so it's a solid changeup yeah I like it
and your answer my answer would be you
know I always believe in my talent I
haven't necessarily been playing that
sport for a while but I don't know if I
could get back into it pretty quick but
yeah I don't know Oh for the Cleveland
Browns Tim come on you believe it I
believe it you could start for the
Browns right now all right that's a yes
that's a yes hey Tim Congrats and good
luck thanks for joining us again that's
Tim Tebow the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience